Hey so what is this some kind of snake
or something your name maybe james
michael tyler but in our eyes you'll
always be gunther Central Perk just
wouldn't have been the same without you
but we have to admit you're bright
bleached blond hair did some permanent
damage to our retinas gunther looking at
you is like staring directly at the Sun
it's hard to believe that over 15 years
have passed since the last episode of
Friends aired in Times Square
friends was known for its hilarious
moments both on and off camera if you
thought the show was funny wait until
you see what was going on behind the
scenes the one where they pivot in
season 5 episode 16 rachel helps Ross
pick out a couch for his new apartment
but things get a little intense when
Ross refuses to pay for delivery and
asks Rachel to help him carry the couch
back to its apartment when Rachel and
Ross get stuck bringing the couch up the
curved staircase Rachel brings Chandler
in for help which makes for one of the
most ridiculous scenes in friends
history but what makes this seem even
more hilarious is the fact that David
Schwimmer couldn't stop laughing while
screaming pivot
it's no secret that Ross isn't the
easiest person to deal with and funny
enough David himself couldn't even stand
his character at the time but it wasn't
just David Jennifer Aniston Matthew
Perry also couldn't contain their
laughter in the show
Ross is acting like a total lunatic and
he gets on Rachel and Chandler's nerves
in a matter of seconds but in real life
this scene made for one of the funniest
blooper reels of all time the one where
Marcel goes bananas bras has had three
great love's in his life
Carol Rachel and Marcel adopting Marcel
helped him get over Carol but owning a
pet monkey wasn't always easy in season
1 episode 19 Ross asks Rachel to babysit
Marcel and things get ugly fast when the
monkey gets away not knowing what to do
Rachel calls Animal Control which only
makes things worse the Casa friends had
to learn to act alongside a few animals
throughout the series there was a monkey
a few ducks in a hilarious cat and while
the entire cast seemed comfortable
around these animals that wasn't always
the case one of the funniest bloopers
involves Jennifer Aniston and Marcel the
monkey here we see Jennifer trying to
act out the scene where she and Marcel
cozy up on the couch and watch TV but
Marcel whose real name is Katie by the
way makes filming the scene a little
challenging Jennifer looks terrified
when the white headed capuchin monkey
starts jumping around her but she laughs
it off the one where Phoebe smells
something during an interview with Conan
O'Brien the cast of friends opened up
about some of their funniest bloopers
and Matt LeBlanc recalled one of his
favorite moments that took place while
filming the episode the one with
Rachel's crush in this episode Monica is
still bitter over the fact that Joey and
Chandler won her apartment she misses
being the group member with the nicest
home so she bakes a batch of cookies to
encourage the gang to come over to her
apartment Phoebe drops the classic line
what do I smell and at this point Joey
is supposed to open the door to find
Monica with a fresh plate of cookies but
instead of sticking to the script I
smell sorry as if to say that he was
responsible for the smell
this got a good laugh out of everyone
but it made filming the rest of the
scene close to impossible every time
Lisa Kudrow asked her question the
actors burst out laughing thinking of
Matt Joe the one with comet Chandler
it's perfectly normal for actors to
encounter some problems when filming
their scenes they can fumble on their
lines trip over their feet or drop props
in the heat of the moment that's exactly
what happened while filming the episode
the one where dr. ramoray dies in this
episode Joey runs in to Central Park and
dashes toward Phoebe while holding the
stack of Soap Opera Digest but while
this scene seemed pretty straightforward
filming it wasn't exactly easy Matt
LeBlanc kept knocking over his chair
this happens take after take causing
Matt to get a little frustrated with
himself but when he finally managed to
keep his chair upright Matthew Perry
decided to play a little prank on his
co-star Matthew came running in
aftermath and launched himself into his
arms in total Chandler fashion everyone
in the coffee house burst out laughing
this hilarious moment made the blooper
reel and had the entire cast the extras
included collecting their sides the one
where they laugh in their sleep friends
is filled with hilarious moments both on
and off the screen
clearly the entire cast a friend had a
lot of fun filming the TV series but
some teens were funnier than others one
scene that comes to mind takes place in
the episode the one with the Knapp
partners in this season 7 episode Ross
and Joey fall asleep on the couch while
watching a movie and when they wake up
they're cuddling
[Applause]
at first they're a little embarrassed
but the nap was so enjoyable that they
decided to try it one more time provoke
Joey and Ross have angelic looks on
their faces
during they're cuddling session sewing
the scene wasn't an easy thing to do
David and Matt couldn't stop themselves
from laughing while shooting the scene
it was close to impossible for them to
get through the material the co-stars
had to film a few takes before they
could keep a straight face and complete
the scene here are the things we post
daily videos about your favorite movies
TV shows and celebrities forget that
subscribe button to stay in the
cinematic loop better yet switch on
notifications by clicking the bell so
you never miss another video if you're
watching on your phone
adjust your YouTube settings to get
notified whenever we upload something
new the one with the pancake flop every
single episode of friends had its fair
share of bloopers while some were pretty
vanilla others did the cast members to
their knees with laughter one of these
moments happened in the episode the one
with Rachel's crush Joey and Chandler
take over as hosts when they win the
girl's apartment fair and square and the
scene Joey is making pancakes and Monica
is in total disbelief
Joey attempts to flip a pancake on to
Monica's plate but misses by a long shot
but when he tries to do it the same with
Phoebe she catches it like a pro you
would think that this moment happened
naturally that's not how it went down in
fact this pancake throat took more than
a few shots to master and is hilarious
behind the scenes moment we see Matt
attempt to throw a pancake on Lisa's
plate only did Matthew in the back of
the head everyone starts laughing at
this unexpected twist
unfortunately the scene didn't make it
into the actual episode the one with the
Hunchback of Central Perk Joey and
Chandler were best friends but when it
comes to their actors acting chummy on
camera we wouldn't exactly call it
acting after all Matthew Perry and Matt
LeBlanc are best friends in real life
too their friendship makes for some
super hilarious bloopers which is
exactly what happened while filming the
episode the one where Joey loses his
insurance in this episode Joey gets a
super painful hernia that causes him to
bend over in agony but seeing that
this state is just too much for Matthew
to handle in this blooper reel we see
Joey attempts to carry a cup of coffee
to the Central Park cows hey will you
grab me a cruller but to properly convey
the amounts of pain his character is in
Matt walks over to the couch in a very
ghoulish way and the mere sight of Matt
is simply too much for Matthew to bear
the actor just can't stop himself from
laughing and his friend which led to
Matt having to reshoot the scene a
handful of times the one where Ben knows
everyone's lines working the child
actors can be challenging especially
when they don't have a lot of experience
their emotions can get the best of them
and they can have a hard time
remembering their lines but that wasn't
the case for twin actors dylan and Cole
Sprouse who posed as Ross's son Ben on
friends and this behind-the-scenes
moment we see one of the Sprouse twins
helping Jennifer Anniston out with her
lines in the episode the one with the
truth about London I was I was your
daddy's girlfriend but you're not
anymore
after schooling Jennifer in front of the
entire crew Jennifer breaks the fourth
wall by giving the camera a wide-eyed
look but this wouldn't be the last time
that a Strauss twin reminded one of his
co-stars of their lines
David's on-screen son reminds him of his
lines in the episode the one with the
holiday armadillo but he doesn't stop
there the kid actor jokingly says man I
know all of his lines it looks like
dylan and Cole Sprouse were professional
actors from the get-go
the one where Cortney pulls a Monica
Courtney Cox did an amazing job at
portraying her eccentric character
Monica Geller
what if there's no room for a ribbon
drawer because the baby stuff takes up
all of the space but after years of
stepping into her shoes Courtney adopted
Monica's special personality in the
episode the one with the cooking class
Monica's restaurant receives a bad
review prompting her to take a cooking
class with Joey this hilarious episode
had us laughing the whole way through
and so did it's gay grill Courtney
pulled a Monica when she was asked to
reshoot a scene from the beginning the
actors captain messing up her lines
instead of doing what the director asked
she started arguing with him both matt
LeBlanc and Matthew Perry laughed at
Courtney as she begged producers to let
it slide and Matt mocks Courtney behind
her back
Matthew tried to argue with Monica
during her prima donna moment but she
clapped back saying that he had just
messed up his lines a bunch of times
just moments before this
behind-the-scenes moment could have been
a scene from friends itself turns out
that Courtney Matt and Matthew are a lot
like the characters they portray on the
show the one where it tastes like feet
during an interview with Conan O'Brien
the cast of friends were asked to reveal
some of their funnies behind the scenes
moment and well there were just so many
to choose from
Conan revealed that after long hours of
filming the cast would often laugh at
how one of their fellow actors
pronounced a certain word and since no
one pronounces words like Ross this
often happens when it was David's turn
to speak in season 6 episode 9 Monica
tasks Rachel with making a trifle and
she messes up the recipe when Ross takes
a bite of the trifle / shepherd's pie he
announces Victor's retreat well as Conan
pointed out the way David said the word
feed send the friends cast into
hysterics Matt could not stop laughing
at this word which made filming the
trifle seen all the more challenging
this blooper is even funnier than the
real scene we can't decide what's
funnier the actual front show or what
went on behind the scenes before you go
tell us who your favorite cast member is
in the comment section below give this
video a big thumbs up if you love
friends thanks for watching the things
we'll see you soon
[Music]